so die nächste frage ist wieso hast du
dein blaues audi alt warst du hast du
deine erste freundin hat die halter
reicht da ich meine ich war etwas
gedacht jetzt willkommen bei einem neuen
video ja leute ich hoffe natürlich geht
es gut mir jetzt setzen wir auf gefallen
früher habe ich alter das geht ja ich
glaube diese polen kommen wieder ne
scheiße auf jeden fall ist mir
aufgefallen oder ich weiß ist noch von
früher ich habe sehr gerne fragen und
antworten videos gemacht das heißt sie
konnten mir sehr viele fragen stellen
die habe ich auch immer sehr gerne
beantwortet das ganze habe ich schon
ungefähr eineinhalb jahren nicht mehr
gemacht und deswegen habe ich euch
gestern auf instagram gefragt weil ich
mir da nicht folgt macht es auf jeden
fall schnell stellt mir doch einfach mal
viele fragen die ich für euch
beantworten kann es sind eine menge
fragen reingegangen ich habe mir die
interessantesten rausgesucht ich will
gar nicht lange lagern und würde sagen
wir beantworten die einfach mal wenn ihr
bock habt auch noch einen part wenn ich
das noch mal öfter machen soll
dann lasst auf jeden fall jetzt mal doch
nach oben da dann sehe ich das ja und ja
dann würde ich mal sagen fangen wir auch
sofort an mit dem fragen und antworten
wie früher war das aber so wenn man
keine idee hatte für den video hat man
einfach fragen beantwortet aber ich habe
noch genug ideen sowie sophie fragt
wirst du oft auf der straße angesprochen
weil du von leuten erkannt wird ist ja
mittlerweile ist es echt so dass ich
immer mehr denke auch man jetzt wirst du
wieder angeguckt jetzt wirst du wieder
also soll natürlich gar nichts negatives
sein ich habe es super gerne wenn mich
leute auf der straße ansprechen und
sagen du bist cool oder so dass das
freut mich natürlich und ich rede dann
auch gerne mit euch oder so allerdings
gibt es natürlich auch situationen wo es
einfach überhaupt nicht passt zum
beispiel wenn man mit freunden entspannt
unterwegs oder so wenn man einfach mal
unter sich sein möchte und da kommt
deshalb öfter mal vor also es wird halt
irgendwie stetig mehr ist ja auch
logisch
deswegen jahr zehn frage bist du der ist
mit seinem wohnort zufrieden also ich
wohne ja in köln eine super super schöne
stadt ist halt komplett einen kontrast
zu meinem dorf sag ich mal oder
kleinstadt wo ich herkomme
trotzdem wir nicht auch einmal sehr froh
wieder mal in der kleinstadt zu sein
einfach weil es ganz anders ist das ist
weniger los man kennt die leute aber
können ist natürlich eine sehr große
stadt mit ganz vielen möglichkeiten und
da hier zu wohnen ist schon echt geil
mit allen leuten die ich hier kenne und
ja ist auf jeden fall eine super super
schöne stadt was wolltest du früher
einmal als beruf waren ganz nämlich
größte schöne grüße war punkt 13
paetzold also ich wollte eigentlich
immer fußballprofi werden ja ganz lange
so bis zwölf oder so und irgendwann habe
ich mir dann gedacht du wirst
grafikdesigner das habe ich dann mal als
praktikum ausgeübt war allerdings der
letzte müll also da hab ich mich gar
nicht wohl gefühlt die ganze zeit vom pc
zu hängen und ja das waren so weine
traumjobs damals und jetzt habe ich aber
eigentlich ein wirklich schön beruf
hobby nebentätigkeit die mir sehr viel
das ermöglicht und das ist eigentlich
das was ich mir immer gewünscht habe
oder als ich bin auf jeden fall richtig
richtig wirklich mit dem was ich machen
kann
und danke wirklich danke das kann man
noch nicht oft genug sagen darauf passt
eigentlich auch gut die nächste frage
von nora und zwar frank nora wärst du
gerne reich ich gehe mal davon aus die
frage ist natürlich darauf bezogen ob
ich gerne viel geld hätte ob ich gerne
millionär wäre oder multimillionär keine
ahnung
natürlich ist es cool wenn man viel geld
hat allerdings ist geld nicht die
einzige sache im leben die einen so
glücklich machen kann wie ich eigentlich
glücklich bin ich denke das sind viel
mehr freunde dass man sich generell
keine sorgen machen muss dass man ja
alles was nicht materiell ist und
natürlich ist es dann schön wenn man
sagen kann gut ich habe jetzt diesen
monat soundso viel geld zur verfügung
und sich damit noch einiges zusätzliche
leisten kann das wertet das ganze
natürlich noch mal so ein bisschen auf
aber trotzdem definiert sich reichtum
meiner meinung nach überhaupt nicht
durch geld gibt genug menschen die haben
sonst was an geld und sind total
unglücklich einfach weil sie die nicht
materiell in sachen nicht so haben wie
andere menschen die dann womöglich viel
glücklicher sind so die marie fragt zu
den fragen aber wie halt war es als du
deine erste freunde hat das kannst du
mich bitte grüßen heißen morgen die
halte ich da ich meine ich war 15
also meine erste freundin hatte ich mit
15 ist finde ich auch einen einigermaßen
normales alter mit zwölf ist das ganze
für mich noch so ein bisschen früh ihr
könnt ja gerne in die kommentare
schreiben wie es bei euch ist wie alt
seid ihr wann hattet ihr eure erste
freude neuen ersten freund wirklich wahr
interessieren wie das wieder so ist ob
es auch schon welche gibt die ja noch
mal am tag
wir sind als 15 aber bei mir war es 15
so die nächste frage ist wieso hast du
ein blaues auge ich habe jetzt ist ein
video hochgeladen
das war auch ein blog allerdings nämlich
um workshops mileys bestimme einen tag
mein leben wenn der ist nämlich gesehen
doch war das letzte video schaut euch
das auf jeden fall an
und da haben viele wieder gefragt wo
alex mir auf der wenn ich mit der canon
aufnehme dann sieht man das nicht
wirklich aber dieses auge und nehmen
diese services das sieht jetzt auch so
ein bisschen bläulich aus und wenn das
licht inhalt passende schimmert und ich
mit meiner sony aufnehme die das ganze
wirklich gestochen scharf macht dann
sieht man da ein blaues auge oder ist
wirkt halt extrem wie ein blaues auge
und ich bin auch eigentlich so der
einzige mensch der das hat ich habe und
zwar werde ich so wöchentlich gefragt
aus dem nichts eigentlich von leuten die
das auch zum ersten mal sehen wenn das
licht hat passend steht auf mein auge
weg das halt extrem blau und dann fragen
die man ja erst ein blaues auge und so
auch viele von euch anscheinend also
sollte ich schon echt oft gefragt nein
ich habe keinen los aber ich habe keinen
aufs auge bekommen oder wenn irgendwo
gegen gerannt
das ist einfach so bei diesem auge dass
ich irgendwie hier eine ader hat oder so
und die ist halt manchmal mehr da als zu
anderer zeit und wenn das nicht dann
halt passen steht wirkt das extrem krass
blau ich schlafe auch genug manchmal
vielleicht nicht aber daran kann es auch
nicht liegen also das habe ich irgendwie
jetzt schon ein paar jahre so aber an
sich fällt auch nicht auf hast du noch
deine weisheitszähne nein habe ich nicht
die sind zum glück noch drin manchmal
schon gedacht die müssen jetzt mal raus
weil es weh tut aber es ist es wieder
normal das ist irgend ein bisschen
komisch irgendwann sehen aus wie ein
hamster für eine woche aber jetzt
sondern ich danke dir manchmal fanpage
ist fragt alex wie fakten alex fakten
zurück
also dazu kann ich dann sehr sehr gerne
auf die seite kenne ich natürlich ich
kenne da so ein paar seiten so die finde
ich auch recht unterhaltsam und lustig
und ich freue mich natürlich immer wenn
leute sich extra mühe geben für mich und
irgendwie was malen oder so ich dann
auch wenn es wohl markieren das ist
immer echt lieb von euch nina frage was
würdest du dir am allerliebsten kaufen
wenn du es könntest was würde ich mir am
allerliebsten kaufen also also was mir
jetzt spontan sofort einfallen würde
einfach weil ich mir das richtig
entspannt vorstellen könnte so erhalten
cooles boot einfach weil ich das so geil
finde wenn leute so ein boot haben und
dann die sonne
darunter geht und so und dann irgendwie
von da nach da fahren können so das
würde mir schon echt cool vorstellen ein
boot war schon echt krass also jetzt
nicht so ein schlauch oder so sondern
wirklich so ein schickes bot wer weiß
vielleicht geht es ja irgendwann mal in
erfüllung
ja oder auch nicht so und wir machen
weiter mit der nächsten frage was war
bis jetzt ein lieblingsreiseziel und
wollen würdest du noch gerne verreisen
als ich kann jetzt erst mal sagen
dieses jahr wird auf jeden fall echt
cool glaube ich ich fahre morgen noch
einmal nach österreich und ein echt
schönen ort glaub ich dann zeigt er uns
später fliege ich nach santorin das ist
in griechenland auch eine super super
schöne insel und da war ich noch nie
aber ich habe es auf bildern gesehen
würde ich auch schon echt gespannt drauf
dann geht es dieses jahr auf jeden fall
noch mal nach spanien also ibiza und
formentera ich weiß nicht wie zu
erkennen wahrscheinlich die meisten von
euch kommentiere ist neben insel und was
ich dieses jahr auch noch super super
gerne machen würde wäre bali einfach
weil ich noch nie auf einem anderen
kontinent war und das einfach mal so ein
komplett anderes leben sein soll bzw ein
komplett anderer eindruck auf einen
selber verschafft auf das leben halt
weil die menschen da komplett anders
ticken und die landschaften auch noch
mal extrem anders aussehen als hier also
das wäre auch schon cool wenn es klappt
bin ich mal gespannt sind kann ich sagen
was war dein lieblingsreiseziel ja
vielleicht wissen dass sie auch einige
von euch bin super gerne auf ibiza
einfach weil ich die insel
total schön finde vom vom meer her und
allem drum und dran also das ist
wirklich mein lieblings reiseziele
hattest du schon viele knochenbrüche
wenn ja warum und wo liebe grüße von ppr
schöne müsse zurück ich hatte in meinem
ganzen leben noch nicht einen
knochenbruch ich weiß nicht wieso es
kann sein dass mein arm einmal gebrochen
war und ich es einfach nicht gemerkt
habe weil der tat wirklichen halt ist ja
weh aber ich bin einfach nicht zum arzt
gegangen und jetzt hält er wieder und
willkommen zur letzten frage die ist von
fabian wäre es besser messi oder ronaldo
an die ganzen ronaldo fans natürlich hat
jeder seine eigenen qualitäten wobei ich
einfach sagen muss dass mich messi viel
mehr fasziniert ich finde er hat einfach
dieses talent dieses lockere talent was
halt bodalgo hat natürlich auch talent
aber ronaldo hat meiner meinung nach
fehlt es durch training geschafft was
ich auch sehr bewundere aber messi
schaue ich super gerne beim
fußballspielen zu und ich freue mich
immer wenn man sie ein tor mehr schießt
als ronaldo ja deswegen ganz klar messi
und ich finde den nächsten fußballer des
jahres sogar sollte auch auf jeden fall
bekommen einfach weil er zurzeit finde
ich mit so ist gut das waren jetzt zwölf
oder 13 fragen ihr könnt weitere gerne
in die kommentare schreiben
falsche noch ein video haben wollt wo
ich frage wann wurde lasst mich das
gerne wissen mit einem daumen nach oben
wissen kreierten nach oben wir sehen uns
eventuell schon morgen wieder muss ich
schauen ob ich so viel ansonsten wünsche
ich euch noch einen schönen tag genießt
das wetter es soll ja echt waren werden
jetzt die woche noch in deutschland und
ich wünsche euch einen schönen tag auf
reinster gemacht